sí buenos días raúl anoche en horas
tardes se pronunciaron algunos de los
diputados que fueron beneficiados con
esta medida del gobierno de nicolás
maduro todos tienen la misma opinión que
es la misma que dijo el líder opositor
juan guaidó a la dio a conocer a través
de las redes sociales donde señalaba que
él está solidario con esta lista de
personas que quedaron excluidas de las
acciones penales sin embargo dijo que
esto se trata y se trata de una trampa
del gobierno de nicolás maduro este
líder opositor opinó que con este con
está medida que tomo nicolás maduro
también está diciendo o confirmando que
tiene una lista de perseguidos y de
personas políticas en el país también
señalaba que nicolás madura lo que
quiere es legitimar un fraude electoral
refiriéndose a las elecciones del
próximo 6 de diciembre que ha llamado el
concejo electoral para escoger una nueva
asamblea nacional y por último también
dijo que el 15 por ciento de estas 110
personas que fueron beneficiados con el
indulto son diputados lo cual quiere
decir a su juicio que la asamblea
nacional
precedida por la oposición ha sido
perseguida estos últimos cinco años
herminia que se sabe hasta el momento
estas liberaciones y además le quiero
preguntar si ya se dieron en su
totalidad
si la tarde ayer en las horas tardes de
la noche se dieron definitivamente todas
las liberaciones de las personas que
estaban detenidas se pudo ver en
imágenes la salida de los diputados como
son en su aprieto y el ver caro de las
instalaciones de la fuerza de acciones
especiales de la policía también se vio
a roberto marrero l el jefe de pacho de
wide o salir de la sede del servicio de
inteligencia el foro penal que la
organización no gubernamental que lleva
los casos de los personas digamos traes
tramitadas por casos políticos dice que
son 368 a las personas que están
detenidas por estas acciones de estos
sólo 50 fueron liberadas ayer por este
indulto y ellos dijeron que dos
adolescentes que se encuentran entre
estas 368 personas no no fueron
liberadas y de las 29 personas mujeres
que están en esta lista sólo dos también
obtuvieron la liberación